Ідея створення цього музею належала
Луньову Афанасію Федоровичу.
Він вважав програму звичайної загальноосвітньої школи
не досконалою в тому плані,
що не приділялося значної уваги
естетичному вихованню дітей.
Тому він й запропонував своїм учням
створити в школі краєзнавчий музей —
музей, який би розповів про історію,
про культуру саме нашого села Пархомівки.
У цій залі у нас етнографічна експозиція.
Ми жартома говоримо, що це дитинство нашого музею,
тому що тут багато експонатів,
які діти ще приносили для свого
першого краєзнавчого музею.
Ви побачите тут і вишивку, і знаряддя праці,
і побутові [речі] різні:
посуд, предмети побуту, одягу.
Така у нас чудова музична скринька —
це подарунок місцевих жителів нашому музею.
Це поліфон. 1865 року випускали
от такі от скриньки.
Зараз я вам продемонструю, як вона працює.
Ви почуєте музику достаровинного романсу.
♪ [грає на поліфоні повільну ритмічну музику] ♪
Афанасій Федорович повіз дітей на екскурсіЇ,
де вони познайомилися з художніми музеями, з галереями.
У дітей, які уже вважали себе такими,
маленькими професійними музеєзнавцями,
виникла ідея створити саме художній музей в селі.
Тому Афанасій Федорович їм запропонував,
для здійснення їхньої мрії,
написати листи і звернутися до відомих художників,
діячів культури, до великих музеїв.
І діти писали ці листи.
Першими хто відгукнувся, це були харківські художники.
Внизу робота Василя Кандинського «Спокій».
а вгорі — Казимир Малевич.
До недавнього часу це була єдина робота в українських музеях,
саме в нашій Пархомівці — «Супрематив 65».
Минулого року Мистецькому Арсеналу  із приватної
колекції подарували роботу Казимира Малевича.
Так що є одна в Мистецькому Арсеналі
і одна от в нашому музеї.
Ви на цих фотографіях можете побачити :
от так діти подорожували. Вони у різних музеях.
Ось вони у Дрездені,
тому що Дрезденська картинна галерея...
Коли у пресі з'явилося дуже багато матеріалу
про цей унікальний шкільний музей,
то вони запросили також наших дітей:
і їздили діти, і побували у Німеччині.
Ці музеї передавали на постійне збереження
до нашого музею свої експонати.
Тому наша колекція дійсно унікальна,
вона представляє шедеври всього світового мистецтва.
Для села наша колекція дійсно така унікальна,
це один із найкращих сільських музеїв нашої України.
Західноєвропейське мистецтво
кінця ХІХ - середини ХХ століття.
У нас є робота Каміля Пісарро,
відомого французького художника,  «Весна».
Ну і також роботи Пабло Пікассо
«Портрет Фредеріка Жуль Кюрі», «Голуб з гілкою та маслиною».
Ці дві роботи нашого музею були подаровані
відомим письменником Іллею Оренбургом,
а йому особисто роботи подарував сам Пікассо.
Ну ви знаєте, що вони з ним
товаришували довгі роки.
І також кераміка Пікассо —
от такий от чудовий глечик.
Я навчалася в нього.
Афанасій Федорович створив клуб,
який називався «Райдуга».
Тих дітей, хто займався музейною справою,
він об'єднав у цей клуб.
На заняттях цього клубу діти вивчали історію світового
мистецтва, знайомились з класичною музикою і літературою.
А от вільний свій час вони віддавали музею.
Тобто 30 років цей музей повністю
обслуговували тільки учні, які займалися в цьому клубі.
Я була і членом цього клубу «Райдуга»,
і 3 роки була директором цього музею з 8 по 10 клас.
Потім так от моя доля склалася,
що я до цього часу працюю в цьому музеї.
В нашому музеї кожен місяць проходять 1 або 2 виставки.
Це художники із різних міст нашої країни,
дослідники представляють тут свої цікаві дуже проєкти
і ми обов'язково залучаємо не тільки
дітей нашої Пархомівської школи, а й Краснокутську гімназію.
Учнів запрошуємо. Ми з ними працюємо,
проводимо з ними майстер-класи.
Влаштовуємо тут їхні виставки,
коли запрошуються діти і батьки.
Все це представляється дійсно
як витвори мистецтва.
Афанасій Федорович своїм прикладом
показав скільки може зробити одна людина.
Тому що його музей це був не просто музей,
це був не просто клуб.
Це була дійсно школа для тих дітей, хто займався,
хто вчився в ній, хто пройшов цей клуб.
Це була школа життя, це була школа знань,
тому що він навчав цих дітей
не просто так сприймати це мистецтво,
він навчав дітей ставленню до життя.
Ставленню до людей.